top gerät in rage und greift seine
kollegin an es sind szenen wie aus einem
film
serge und christopher police von der
city of sunrise police in florida nimmt
einen verdächtigen fest der cop mit 21
jähriger berufserfahrung ist eigentlich
ein alter hase trotzdem gerät er in
einen heftigen streit mit dem
festgenommenen um
schlimmeres zu verhindern will seine
junge kollegin zurückziehen doch dann
passiert das unfassbare in
einer cholerischen anwandlung dreht sich
der 46-jährige um und packt die beamten
an der kehle er will sie offenbar zu
recht reisen eine body cam hat den
vorfall aufgezeichnet
laut behörden hat die junge frau genau
das richtige getan und versuchte die
situation zu deeskalieren
so wie es in der polizeiakademie gelehrt
wird police wurde vorläufig suspendiert
gegen ihn wird jetzt intern ermittelt